how does an economist and a climate
scientist and a journalist that writes
about climate see the world differently
what are the strengths and potential
blind spots of each discipline I mean
that's just sort of just so people may
may be aware I think you'll be able to
fall into the economics Camp a bit
there's climate scientists right and
this climate scientists adjacent people
like who hang some of my best friends
are climate scientists kind of which is
I think where you fall in because you're
a journalist you've been writing it so
you're not completely
in the trenches of doing the work you're
just up into the trenches every once in
a while so can you speak to that maybe
Bjorn like what's what does the world
look like to an economist
let's try to empathize with these beings
that uh you know unfortunately has
fallen into the
disreputable uh economics yeah so so uh
I think I think the the main point that
that I've been trying for a long time
and I think that's also a little bit
what Andy has been talking about for a
very long time the whole conversation
was about what does the science tell us
is is it global warming real and and to
me it's much more what can we actually
do what are the policies that we can
take and how effective are they going to
be so the conversation we just had about
electric cars is a good example of how
an economist think about look you gotta
you this is not a question about whether
you feel morally vert true so whether
you know you can sort of display how
much you care about the environment this
is about how much you actually ended up
affecting the world and the honest
answers that you know electric cars
right now in the next decade or so will
have a fairly small impact and
unfortunately right now at a very high
cost because we're basically subsidizing
these things at five or ten thousand
Dollars around the world uh per per car
that that's just not it's not really
sustainable but it's certainly not a
very great way to cut carbon emissions
so I would be the kind of guy and
Economist would be the types of people
who would say is there a smarter way
where you for less money can for
instance cut more CO2 and the obvious
answer is yes that's what we've seen for
instance with uh fracking uh the the
fact that the US went from a lot of coal
to a lot of gas because gas became
incredibly cheap because gas emits about
half as much as as coal does when you
use it for elect uh for power that
basically cut more carbon emissions than
pretty much any other single thing and
we should get the rest of the world in
some sense to frac because it's really
cheap there are some problems and
absolutely we can we can also have that
conversation there is no technology is
Problem free but fundamentally it's an
incredibly cheap way to get people to
cut a lot of CO2 it's not the final
solution because it's still a fossil
fuel but it's a much better fossil fuel
if you will and it's much more realistic
to do that so that's one part of the
thing the other one is when we talked
about for instance uh how do we help
people in Florida who gets hit by
hurricane or how do we hit help people
that get damaged in flash floods the
people who are in who are in uh in heat
waves and the symbol the simple answer
is there's a lot of very very cheap and
effective things that we could do first
so most climate people will tend to sort
of say we gotta you know uh get rid of
all carbon emissions we've got to change
our entire uh the the engine the uh the
the sort of powers the world and has
powered us for the last 200 years
and that's all good and well but it's
really really hard to do and it's
probably not going to do very much and
even if you succeed it it would only
help you know future victims of future
hurricane the ends in Florida a tiny
tiny bit at best so instead let's try to
focus on not getting people to build
right on the waterfront where you're
incredibly vulnerable and where you're
very likely to get hit where we
subsidize people uh with uh with Federal
Insurance again which is you know
actually losing money so we're much more
about saying it's not a science question
I just take the science for granted yes
there is a problem with climate change
but it's much more about saying how can
we make smart decisions can I ask you
about blind spots when you reduce stuff
to numbers the costs and benefits
is there stuff you might miss
about that are important to the
flourishing of the human species so
everyone will have to say of course
there must be blind spots but I don't
know what they are but yeah I'm I'm sure
uh Andy and would probably be better at
telling me what they are uh so we try to
incorporate all of it but obviously
we're not successful we you can't
incorporate everything for instance in
the cost benefit analysis but but the
point is in some way
um I I would worry a lot about this if
we were you know sort of close to
Perfection human race we're doing almost
everything right but we're not quite
right then we need to get the last
digits right but I think it's much more
the you know and the the point that I
tried to make before that we're all
we're all focused on going to an
electric car or you know something else
rather than uh fracking we're all
focused on cutting carbon emissions
instead of reducing vulnerability so
we're simply getting it orders of
magnitude wrong uh and and while I'm
sure I have blind blind spots I think
they're probably not big enough to to
overturn that point Andy was Bjorn and
economists are all wrong about
everything well the models we could
spend a whole day on models uh their
economic models there's this thing
called optimization models the there
were two big ones used to assess the
U.S plan this new big Ira inflation
reduction package and they're fine
they're a starting point for
understanding
what's possible but as this gets to the
journalism part or the public part
you have to look at the caveats you have
to look at what model economists
expressly exclude things that are not
modelable and if you look in the fine
print on the repeat project the
Princeton version of the assessment of
the recent giant legislation
the fine print is the front page for me
is a deep diving journalist because it
says we didn't include any sources of
friction meaning right resistance to
putting new transmission lines through
your community or people who don't want
um mining in America because we've
exported all of our mining we mine our
Cobalt and Congo you know and trying to
get a new mine in Nevada
was a fraught fight that took more than
10 years for lithium
so so if you're excluding those elements
from your model which on the surface
makes this 370 billion dollar package
have an emissions reduction trajectory
that's really pretty good
and you're not saying in your first line
by the way these are the things we're
not considering
that's the job of a journalist summarize
all of human history with that one word
friction
yeah yeah well inertia friction implies
there's a force that's already being
resisted but there's also inertia which
is a huge part of our you know we have a
status quo bias